who wants to be a millionaire well
everybody but how likely you are to
strike it rich depends on age education
and perhaps most importantly race more
than 22 percent of middle-aged
college-educated asian-americans have a
net worth of at least 1 million dollars
and whites aren't far behind 21.5
percent are millionaires but the picture
is much bleaker for Hispanics and blacks
only about six and a half percent in
each group have networks of a million
dollars or more education benefits
people across all races but it helps
some people more than others only 4.4
percent of white people with a high
school degree are millionaires that
number jumps to almost 40% for whites
with a graduate degree for blacks though
it turns out that in advanced degrees no
guarantee of financial success less than
1% of black people with a high school
degree are millionaires and that
increases to just 6.7% for blacks with
graduate degrees that means a black
American with a graduate degree has only
a slightly better chance of becoming a
millionaire than a white American with a
high school diploma people's chances of
being rich do increase with age since
people under 40 generally make less
money and have had less time to save up
an Asian American under 40 has a 2.4
percent chance of being a millionaire
and those odds soared a 21 percent by
the time they are nearing or in
retirement for whites the odds are
slightly less 2.1 percent to 19 percent
but for Hispanics those chances barely
budge from less than 1% when they're
young to 2.3 percent when they're
retired and for black Americans the odds
of becoming a millionaire by retirement
age or less than 2 percent data like
these have left researchers scratching
their heads to explain why such big
wealth gaps exist among racial groups
education debt loads and discriminatory
hiring practices likely play a role but
the data show that the deck is clearly
stacked against some Americans when it
comes to climbing the economic
letter